you know you've never really told me  what happened  I don't know nearly a year after the  sudden death of the beloved Belgian  actor there are still unanswered  questions did you notice anything  unusual about his behavior in the last  two days the two of you were in the  process of separating do you know who he  might have been hanging out with or  where he might have gone what's the  matter cat got your tongue I know he was  here the night he died I saw you at that  club the other night oh is that why are  you here playing detective why do you go  there  funny he'll back a layer and no one's  when they seem to be how well did you  know Stefan had a lot of secrets like  what he called you  why you would help the trigger  what are you doing in town other than  behaving badly the only fault was you  tampering with the evidence he died of a  broken heart something happened to him  some things are just meant to be  you